we are in problem 1818 a time so they
write this give us an equation H of T is
equal to C minus D minus 4t all of that
squared at time equals zero a ball was
thrown up from an initial height of 6
feet until the ball hit the ground is
heightened feet after T seconds was
given by the function H above and with C
and D are positive constants so they're
telling us at time zero we're already at
height six right so H of 0 x 0 the
height is already six if the ball
reaches its maximum height of 100 six
feet a time 2.5 so H of 2.5 is equal to
106 what is the height and feed of the
ball at time T equals 1 so we want to
figure out H of one that's what they
want to know so in order to figure out H
of one we essentially have to figure out
what C and D are going to be right so
how can we do that well we know what H
of 0 is so let's let's substitute so H
of 0 gives us this let's put t equals 0
here you get C minus D minus 4 times 0 4
times 0 squared and that is equal to 6
and then if we simplify this this is of
course 0 right so you get you get c
minus d squared is equal to 6 now the
second equation H of 2.5 is equal to 106
so that means that C minus D minus
what's 4 x 2.5 4 x 2.5 is 10 right
output 2.5 in 40 so do you mind I just
did that to save some space d minus 10
squared and then that is equal to 106
and now if we want to multiply this out
just to see where this takes us because
actual
don't know where will you get c- and
then we output in brackets going to be a
long expression multiplying this out you
get d squared minus 20 d plus 100 all of
that equals 106 and then distribute the
negative sign so you get C squared I'm
sorry this isn't a square don't know
where I got the squared from see what
happens when you take the s80 c minus d
squared plus 20 d minus 100 i just
distributed the negative sign is equal
to 106 and then let's see we could add
100 to both sides you get c minus d
squared plus 20 d is equal to 206 i just
added hundred to both sides so we're
left with two equations we're left with
this c minus d squared is equal to 6 and
then we're left with this c minus d
squared plus 20 d is equal to 206 and
something should be jumping out at you
there's a C minus d squared in both
terms c minus t squared is 4 oh no sorry
c minus t squared is 6 the the previous
equation tells us so we can substitute
six right here so we put six there you
get 6 plus 20 d is equal to 206 subtract
six from both sides 20 d is equal to 200
d is equal to 10 now if we substitute d
equals 10 back into c minus d squared
what do we have d is equal to 10 right
so c minus 100 is equal to 6 or c is
equal to 106 and if you have an
intuition for how parabolas look you
probably could have not guessed you
probably would have known that you would
have known that c is actually going to
be the peak point of this parabola and
they tell us that the peak point is at
Point 106 and then you could have solved
for D from there but if you didn't have
that intuition you could have just
chucked through the algebra like we just
did so we no see we know d so we know
the function is now H of T is equal to
106 minus
10-40 all of that squared and so we want
to know what happens when T equals one
so that's so H of 1 is equal to 100 and
6-10 10 minus with 4 times 1 so 10 minus
4 squared so that equals 106 minus 6
squared equals 106 minus 36 which is
equal to 70 and we are done H of 1 is
equal to 70 which took us a little time
but it was worth it I'll see you in the
next second